anyone who holds more than just a
passing knowledge of the SCP Foundation
has likely heard the name of one Dr Jack
Bright Like A lot of the other
high-ranking staff his name carries with
it a reputation for anomalous expertise
far beyond many working at the
foundation having risen through the
ranks and achieved the position of
personnel director for site 17 19 and
63. Dr bright may just seem like a
highly competent and devoted member of
the organization but the history of the
man himself is one that will likely
forever be linked with tragedy and
Trauma Jack Bright's life has been
turbulent to say the least with themes
of rebirth and regeneration constantly
following him and his family and all the
curses that those ideas bring born to
Adam and Evelyn Bright Young Jack has
sadly never experienced what many would
consider an ordinary life see both his
parents were also researchers within the
SCP Foundation meaning that since birth
Jack Bright has never known a life that
wasn't linked with the foundation and
its many anomalous happenings and it
didn't stop there either at some point
Dr Adam bright would rise through the
ranks of the foundation much like his
son would later come to do Adam
progressed from researcher to Personnel
director to site director and then
eventually even to the high station of
o5 council member but this career
trajectory within the foundation was cut
short when Jack Bright's father met an
untimely end assassinated on the orders
of his fellow o5 council members but why
what could have led to Young Jack
suffering the loss of his
foundation-employed father well it had
to do with the other bright children you
see Jack was far from an only child in
fact he had a considerable number of
siblings while you might be forgiven for
thinking this would provide a younger
Jack Bright with equals friends that he
would at least endure his anomalous
adjacent childhood with this was sadly
not the case one of Jack's Brothers TJ
bright was born with his very own
anomalous abilities TJ had something of
a gift for healing possessing the power
to absorb the injuries and illnesses of
anyone around him purely through
physical touch but the unfortunate side
effect is that TJ also takes on another
person's ailments himself experiencing
their pain and sickness so they don't
have to if you're Jack Bright it had to
be hard to see your younger brother
suffering from wounds and diseases
passed on to him so that others don't
suffer but there's still the lingering
question what happened to Jack and TJ's
father Adam what led to his
assassination and what role did TJ play
in the events leading up to that
untimely death well like much of Dr
Bright's family life it began with a
tragedy trying for another baby Adam and
Evelyn eventually had a daughter giving
jack TJ and their other siblings a new
sister however this was sadly
short-lived as the newest member of the
bright family was stillborn bearing
witness to the grief that would have
caused his parents was no doubt hard on
Jack but even more upsetting was what
came next naturally having both studied
anomalies with within the SCP Foundation
Evelyn and Adam were willing to Define
death itself in order to get their
newborn daughter back and luckily for
them they had been presented with the
perfect anomaly to achieve this goal in
the form of their young son TJ and his
regenerative Powers however what
resulted was a creature that later
became known as
scp-321 while TJ was able to revive the
child her body aged at a rapidly
accelerated rate she became devoid of
melanin in her hair eyes and skin still
able to vocalize but unable to
intelligibly speak
scp-321 is known to have spatial
awareness issues as well as a low level
of Intelligence on top of that scp-321
seems to have inherited some of her
brother TJ Bright's healing abilities
capable of regenerating any injury she
suffers at five times the normal speed
attributed to an overproduction of stem
cells it was also the this that caused
her body to rapidly age and grow with no
signs of stopping taken in by the SCP
Foundation and given the designation
along with TJ who became known as
scp-590
scp-321 was separated from the rest of
the bright family Adam still a junior
researcher at the time pleaded with his
foundation superiors for his daughter to
be released back into the care of her
family every time he made the request it
was denied it didn't seem to matter how
much higher up the managerial ladder of
the SCP Foundation Adam bright climbed
there always seemed to be a message from
above telling him no in time he was
appointed to the o5 council it was then
that Adam bright issued a mandate for
scp-321's immediate release and the rest
of the council didn't take kindly to
that trying to get his daughter back
cost Adam his life and meant that young
Jack Bright had lost not only one of his
brothers and a sister but a father too
Jack Bright assisted the SCP Foundation
with keeping his brother TJ or scp-590
contained for his own safety unlike his
remaining siblings Jack still seemed
eager to follow in the footsteps of his
mom and dad another of his sisters
Claire Pierce was angered by the
foundation's actions and how they had
treated her family this caused her to
join up with the Serpent's hand a group
of Interest with the goal of one day
exposing the SCP Foundation to the world
then there was Michael bright who had
the opposite reaction to his sister he
devoted himself to the foundation
becoming one of their most skilled and
highly efficient field operatives known
to some as agent Cowboy needless to say
there remains plenty of division between
the bright siblings something that would
undoubtedly exact a heavy toll on Jack
who for his part continued his family's
Legacy by joining the foundation as a
junior researcher this is where his life
would once again be altered forever to
begin with Jack seemed to have it easier
than most starting out at the SCP
Foundation as previously mentioned the
bright name already carried significant
pull within the organization not only
allowing him to get his foot through the
proverbial door but also giving jack a
much needed win after his past family
troubles after all he had a considerable
amount of emotional baggage and Trauma
to deal with so the up-and-coming junior
researcher perhaps deserved to Coast by
for a while although it wouldn't last
long and Jack Bright would be
irreversibly and irreparably changed on
one fateful day it was a seemingly
menial task a job that could have been
done by anyone else and things might
have turned out completely different if
they had but yet in giving it to a
certain Junior researcher who was in
good standing the foundation completely
reoriented the trajectory of Jack's life
he had been assigned to perform research
on scp-963 an ornate and rather
beautiful amulet of Unknown Origin and
purpose the piece was constructed from
elegant white gold sporting an oval-cut
Ruby surrounded by 13 brilliant cut
diamonds in a starburst pattern it was a
truly Exquisite and well-crafted piece
of jewelry with a rather strange
property to it not yet realizing the
active anomalous effects of the amulet
Dr bright made the honest mistake of
touching scp-963 with his bare hands it
was purely an act of human error
avoidable and yet carrying consequences
that would last a lifetime or several
you see as it so happened the exact same
fateful day that Dr bright had made the
mistake of allowing scp-963 to make
contact with his skin another anomaly
had simultaneously managed to breach
containment
scp-076-2 better known as able The
Immortal Warrior tore his way through
the foundation pulling his bladed
Weaponry out of a pocket Dimension and
cutting down any Personnel in this path
as he continued his Rampage when the
slaughter was over the dust cleared and
able recontained Junior researcher Jack
Bright laid dead tragically slaying
during the breach or so at first seemed
it was during the cleanup in the
aftermath of Abel's rampage that a
member of d-class personnel named Tom
Higley was assigned to dispose of the
bodies left in the wake of the undying
Warriors Massacre that was when Tom
unknowingly picked up the amulet that Dr
bright had been holding when he was
killed instantly the d-class suffered a
peculiar change one that would soon
become a regular Occurrence at the SCP
Foundation Tom Higley became Dr Jack
Bright once again like with his brother
TJ's anomalous powers and the tragedy of
his stillborn sister
scp-321 the theme of rebirth and
regeneration became a core part of
Jack's life he was alive once again and
inhabiting a new body now this might
might seem like a positive development
for the aspiring Junior researcher but
as Jack Bright would soon learn the cost
of coming back from the dead was a hefty
toll to pay after the foundation had
established that the d-class now wearing
the amulet was indeed the person he
claimed to be they quickly discovered
that removing scp-963 from the wearer
would cause all higher brain function to
shut down immediately replacing the
Amulet the body of Tom Higley was able
to move and speak once again albeit with
the voice and consciousness of Jack
Bright through his continued
experimentation with the artifact Dr
bright discovered that it acted as a
vessel for his Consciousness his
collected memories and his personality
they were all seemingly stored within
scp-963 and could be transferred into a
new body when the amulet was worn by
someone else however part of the high
cost of Jack's Newfound immortality was
the immediate loss of another person for
the sake of his continued life placing
The Amulet on someone else would erase
everything about who they were
effectively killing them and wiping them
clean to make room for Jack himself it
was only thanks to his mistake of being
the last person to hold the amulet along
with being killed by Abel directly
afterwards that had now led to Jack
being unable to die of course the other
large part of the cost Jack had to pay
for living forever was that he
essentially now had to live as a
parasite passed on from house to host at
a regular rate he learned that after 30
days of sustained continuous contact
with scp-963 Jack's Consciousness could
become permanently affixed to a new body
if the amulet was removed after this
occurred then Bright's Consciousness
could still be passed on to a new body
meaning that he could in theory at least
create multiple copies of himself by
transferring into new host bodies via
the amulet and allowing them to wear it
for 30 days at a time to make the change
permanent naturally as they so often
tend to do the SCP Foundation imposed
sanctions and restrictions to prevent
the scenario from unfolding executing
any hosts wearing the amulet before they
could reach the 30-day permanent
transfer threshold afterwards scp-963
and Dr Bright's Consciousness would be
passed on to a new host and the cycle
would continue however after witnessing
The Immortal researchers continued
dedication to their cause the foundation
eventually relaxed its rules for Dr
bright Jack then went on to continue to
work with the foundation Rising through
the ranks and achieving promotions to
higher stations eventually becoming one
of the most well-known researchers of
scps to ever live but all the while he
did further examination of scp-963 you
might be fooled into thinking that
immortality would be a gift but to Jack
Bright it is a never-ending curse moving
from host to host only surviving because
of a simple mistake that changed his
circumstances in ways he could never
have for scene Dr bright lives in
frustration and longs to be free from
what he views as a curse of eternal life
he is perpetually aware that he'll
outlive everyone at the foundation have
to watch countless people die while he
lives on just like he had to live on
after the death of his father this curse
of immortality has led Dr Wright too
long for a permanent death ironically he
only became a part of scp-963 in a
moment of trying not to die and now
can't at all making the story of Dr Jack
Bright a truly saddening Tale Now go and
check out top 25 sad scps compilation
and Dr clef SCP Foundation researcher
for more Foundation inner workings and
unrelenting misery